millions of families across the u.s have
been waiting for this
one by one troops in the state of
indiana unloaded boxes of baby formula
shipped from an american air base in
germany
it's enough to make about 500 000
bottles it's a terrifying feeling to
know that you don't know where the next
meal is gonna come from so i i'm able to
provide breast milk for her sometimes
which is great um but i just don't i i'm
not it's the one
the next stop is a distribution center
before sending the supplies to hospitals
and pharmacies
agriculture secretary tom vilsack says
they're working around the clock the
president has instructed us
to look for every opportunity to
increase supply
the problem began with delays in the
supply chain caused by the pandemic
things got worse in february when a top
baby formula company abbott issued a
recall and closed one of its major
manufacturing plants
it's scheduled to reopen next week but
the product won't be ready for about two
months
under pressure and criticism president
joe biden signed a bill to expand
production across countries airplanes
fuel
it was a lot of work to get it from
germany to here that fast so
they're doing they're doing what they
can to try to help
but the shortage isn't over yet this
delivery covers about 15 percent of the
nationwide shortage
katie lopisodo yan al jazeera